hey guys today i'm bringing you
something way different that i've been
uploading so far by now this video is
not like my other usual videos it's not
a theory video or video about season 7
news that's reason of leaving out my
usual spoiler warning at the beginning
of this video today i'm going to talk
about honorable acts of two characters
ned stark and jaime lannister i know
that most of you right now don't even
want to consider jaime as an honorable
man at least not compared to ned stark
but after this video you might change
your mind i'm fully aware of jamie's few
dishonorable and really bad acts like
throwing bran throughout the window in
favor to save his sister's pride but you
have to admit that we all hated jaime
only because of his act in the first
season but since the third season jaime
grew in our eyes with very much
honorable acts of his especially with
relieving the true background story and
the true reasons of his betrayal or the
king gary's targaryen which he told to
brienne it's important for you to know
that i don't want to humble or point out
the honor of either jaime or nat i'm
going to compare a few of their acts and
point out some differences let's start
with jaime lannister on one hand a lot
of people consider jaime as an honorable
or even more honorable than ned without
making any mistake but only from one
view which this fact kind of confirms
this next fight against sarah jordan
we're going to compare with jaime's
fight against ned stark and there are a
few big differences when jaime came a
dozen lannister soldiers to find ned
stark who was with his four or five
soldiers almost same scenario happened
but with a few important differences
while let's start with his companions
killed the only one warrior that
followed by sir arthur day inside them
all four of them then attacked serger
dane now is a huge difference in jaime's
fight
jaime used his lannister soldiers only
to ken as protectors and then jaime
attacked ned alone and font alone
against ned stark no matter that he
could have used all dozens lancer
soldiers because the ratio was also the
same compared to ned's fight against
herrartur but jaime won in a fair fight
he wanted to fight one-on-one that's one
difference between those two fights but
the second difference is huge and could
he find jaime as way more honorable man
than ned just like when sarah arthur
gets stabbed from the back by reed this
time that was stabbed from the back by
one lannister soldier only this time
jaime didn't want any man to interrupt
his fight against ned furthermore after
the only lancer soldier stabbed in net's
leg jaime knocked him so hard that he
fell on the ground because as jaime's
face in that scene says itself jaime
wanted as i've already said fair
one-on-one fight
this is the moment in which we've seen
difference between jaime lannister and
ned stark the main difference is in this
fact which is fairness while ned decided
to kill wounded sir arthur dayne after
he got stabbed from the back jaime
didn't want to kill ned stark after he
also got stabbed from the back because
as jaime said to his father it wouldn't
have been klingkill
now you see this huge difference between
james and ned's act in those two fights
right jaime considered killing nat who
got stabbed from the back by someone
else as dishonorable act while ned
killed sir archer dane who also got
stabbed from the back after they
coveredly outnumbered him this is the
only one way of the view as we said in
the beginning of this video there are a
few sides of you at these fights on the
other hand some people could also see
the scene in which nat kills her arter
dane as ned's mercy towards him some
could even consider it as sir archer's
request to finish him
it could mean that sword of the morning
shall i say requested from that star to
save him from the pain and to give him a
quick death
it could also mean since he was the
great swordsman that the seven kingdoms
has ever had that he didn't want to be
killed by some ordinary man by someone
in her blade it could mean that the fame
and legendary knights throughout her
dame was known as the sword of the
morning might want to be killed by a
hero in that rebellion by ned stark and
to be killed by the most famous war in
seven kingdoms by his famous ancestral
greatsword called dawn as i've said in
the beginning of this video we don't
want to humble any of those characters
on her both jaime lannister and ned
stark could and should be considered as
the man of honor ned stark is honorable
because of many things he had done in
his life we would highlight ned's
promise to his sister lyanna as the most
honorable thing that ned did in his life
ned presented jon as his own son in
favor to protect him he kept his promise
to his sister throughout his whole life
that didn't even tell his own wife about
jon's real mother kaitlyn stark asked
only once about john smither on which
ned answer calledly with never asked me
about jon he is my blood and that's all
you need to know unbelievable but
honorable that didn't pronounce any
lying his answer john actually has ned's
blood since that isn't his uncle
there are as i lord mentioned a lot of
vulnerable things that ned did
throughout his life but problems that he
gave to his sister and kept her out his
whole life is definitely the most
honorable one while on the other side
jaime also did a lot of honorable acts
throughout his life the most important
one is saving thousands of innocent
lives by killing the mad king jaime
lannister is for this sag the true hero
but still holvester still doesn't
respect him furthermore they are mocking
him by calling him king slayer yeah he
killed the king whom he was supposed to
guard with his own life but the only
reason of jaime killing king gair is
targaryen is because of king's intention
to burn the whole king's landing along
with all people within it jaime should
be respected by every living man and
woman in king's landing but he doesn't
want to prove to everyone else the real
reason for his let's call it betrayal
over the mad king because he thoughts
are that it wouldn't change other
people's opinion about him since no one
would believe him actually we can't call
jaime's act as betrayal over the king
garys since he was also sworn to protect
innocent people lives which he did by
killing mad king
here's the important fact that all of
you should know jaime didn't decide to
betray king aerys not even after king's
troops lost the battle on the
battlefield jaime also counseled the mad
king not to open the king's landing
gates for his own father david lannister
because jaime knew that his father would
betray the king from the other honorable
acts throughout jaime's life we would
highlight sami brienne of tar twice
the first time jamie cebrian from being
raped by baldwin soldiers which led to
jaime losing his hand in our opinion if
jamie stayed out from everything and
didn't lie about brienne's father's
wealth in favor to save her from being
raped he wouldn't have made a lot angry
over his own arrogance which wouldn't
result in jaime losing his hand since
they would have had fun with brienne the
second time brian was throwing into
gladiator pit giving only one sword to
fight against the bear as a result of
lucky finding out that jim lied to him
about brienne father's wealth
once again jaime ran it he jumped into
the pit and with the help of steel
shanks who was bound by his duty to
ensure jaime's arrival in king's landing
jaime and brienne somehow managed to
escape from the pit in our opinion both
jaime and ned are the true definition of
honorable men both but in different ways
i'm aware that some of you don't want to
consider jaime as an honorable man
mostly because of his incest with his
sister here's the one fact for all of
you house targaryens doing insecure are
the most of their history but however
many of them were or even are heroes in
the eyes of many people so what's the
difference to conclude this ned stark
and jaime lannister should be respected
by all of us and by all the people in
westeros because of their many honorable
acts throughout their lives well jaime
still have a plenty time to do many
honorable things firstly he need to
understand who his sister and lover
really is and for whom he should fight
i'm sure the gym is going to play the
main role in season 7 and that he is
going to do many honorable things in the
upcoming seasons
the important thing for jaime is to
realize that his sister is the same
lunatic as the mad king was and to
realize that he killed the king whom he
was supposed to defend because of his
intention to murder king's landing which
cersei actually have done in previous
season
i'm aware that aries targaryen attended
to burn down the whole king's landing
but still cersei killed a lot of
innocent people by destroying the great
scepter bailor those same innocent
people whom jaime was protected from the
king heirs while there were a lot of
speculations about jaime's loyalty to
cersei after the season 6 finale after
james looked towards cersei on the iron
throne with a lot of disappointment in
his eyes after he found out that his
sister and lover cersei used the
wildfire to destroy one part of king's
landing along with many innocent people
which also led to their son's suicide we
thought that jaime would immediately
break every connection between them in
the upcoming season but from the league
photos we can still see jaime fighting
on the lannister's side but be aware
that this doesn't mean that he will
forgive cersei for what she has done in
our opinion jaime is going to hate
cersei in the upcoming season but still
he's a lannister he isn't some servant
of cersei's that could just go away
james lannister and is going to do
everything he can to save his house from
disappearing in the next few days i'm
going to make a video about jaime's fate
in season 7 supported by all league
photos league plot and of course with
few theories of mine if you like this
kind of video that i brought you today
let me know in comment section down
below